Hey Leanne revamped,
there is no sheen. Leann? Yes,
he is Pronoun and element top right king,
the most noble guy.
If there was Shelia,
how fine, why lie?
She might be
[inaudible].
I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab and today
elements. Yeah,
I carried your oxygen and you walked
beside me through the lobby commenting on
the decor when you needed
to stop for breath.
Your hand ran light and steady
by the ocean of breath twice. I remember
I carried your oxygen. It was heavy.
A bleak alloy.
Wow.
Steel
[inaudible] this hour is a collaboration
with poets like the ones you heard and
really are more of musicians,
reporters and of course the
periodic table of elements.
Speaking of which
our producer Soren Wheeler,
who's sodium sparked brain conceived to
this entire show. He will lead us off.
So this one starts with a
story I heard from Jamie Lowe.
She's a writer in Brooklyn and at the
heart of this story is this particular 24
hour period in Jamie's life that
um, she is uneasy about have,
let's just set it up for one second.
So what are we about to watch?
I'm not actually exactly sure where
it starts, but we're about to watch,
I think the night before Valentine's Day,
2001 I eventually convinced her to sit
down with producer Latif Nasser and sort
of just walk us through the
tape. Go for it. You're,
you're in control there with
the spacebar. All right.
Yeah. Mine your honor. [inaudible] Jamie.
Hey Jamie. Mike.
It's nighttime. Uh, Jamie
and her friend Mike,
he's the one filming there outside his
apartment in Brooklyn and the cameras
pointed at a bunch of high school
students who were just walking by.
So what's the deal?
Tell say you want to be
an actress, right? Yeah. Tell
me you need to, I love that.
Good for you. So yeah.
Really? Yeah. That's so cool.
It's by any other name would
smell as sweet. Yeah. Is My enemy
Montague. What's Montague? It is nor
hand, nor foot, nor on north face,
nor any other part belongs to the man.
I'm like egging them on to recite
it. Retain that dear perfection,
which she owes with that, that
title, everyone you adopt a name.
And for the name,
which is no part of the take all my
sisters in a part of that same screaming
babies. So wait, camera eventually turns
to Jamie. She's sitting on the stoop,
a huge curly hair, wide eyes,
and she starts to sing the
kids a song. It does. You know,
cause I can't see,
I was pretty convinced that I was
like a great singer and rapper.
She likes sounded real voice.
Good reviews. Sing a lot in. No,
never. I am not as anger. I just started
thinking like that. I don't know.
What was it like? Well
one of the audio drapes,
it was fun to watch people react or
she made people personally happy.
Whoever she wanted. She would.
We went to flea markets and she would
talk to people and she would pull this
spark out of them. It, it just
felt like New York loved her.
That's Mike Ryan Guy
Holding the camera. Yes.
He'd only met Jamie just
three weeks earlier.
Not long after we moved to New York
and they pretty much instantly became
friends. She was so positive.
As I recall. She's talking to
some little kids on a stoop,
but then that next four or
five hours was pretty defining.
Yeah. By Cameron, my friends,
they cut to Mike's apartment.
I think you're just walking
around and Umbra and open dress,
sparkly red bra and plastic bag,
plastic bag on the stomach. Belly dancing.
You might have to shield your
eyes, but okay. There we go.
That's four hours.
That's my case. Sleeping. Oh boy. Okay.
Combining. It's
Valentine's Day, 2001 okay.
That's Kumquats and Avocados.
The kumquats I picked with my grandpa
and then come Quechee hope three or four
days ago. That's kind of true.
There's three breakfast bows.
What is all that stuff? Cutting
board. Cut Up power bars
from the President I gave
you at tightening the cup
of wine that we're going to
drink and a cup of wine. Of course
it's seven 40 in the morning,
so do you need a nap or anything at
noon or do you just keep [inaudible] oh,
here's a dollar. Keep
pouring my ink. Sure. Jamie,
what's going to happen today? Today I'm
going to contact him to face to debate.
Core of Bush. Neda or rock
10 Fidel Castro. Yeah.
He's an amazing man. [inaudible] okay.
I'm going to have to be about
any about anything, right?
I didn't think that those
scientists, this one. Yeah.
Were you, what were meaning that
literally,
that you were going to go on
MTV and debate Gore v Bush
and then that is exactly
what I had in mind for the day.
I thought it was make-believe.
It seemed harmless.
It just didn't occur to me that what I
was seeing with somebody who had deviated
substantially from who they wanted to do.
It's changed the world. Jesus Christ.
Eventually Mike got up, had to go to work.
Jamie took off for a while and then later
that day she showed up at his office
and at first everything seemed sort of
fine, but within 20 minutes she said,
hey, tell you what, can we
go to the roof really fast?
What?
And that immediately
we got me uncomfortable. Yeah.
So, okay, over pants,
flo wrap around skirt.
We are now going to the roof and
you ready to be blown out your feet?
You can hear, he is done.
Like the day has been insane.
This isn't the end of that day.
Snowy seventh avenue rooftop.
What you, what does this
anything, what is that
piece of yarn?
Mr Mike? Brian
tonight can after work
at five
on top of the world at
the World Trade Center
by wireline. Yeah.
If you want tonight set up
January,
that's when at that point he
was like done. We're done.
Wow. Eh? Yeah. I mean,
yeah, that's when it, it hit me that, um,
there is no way that any of this
reflects what she would actually want.
I don't know if delusional is a kind
word here and if it's not, I apologize.
But if she's delusional enough to
think that we should get married,
is she delusional enough
to think she can fly?
Will she be distraught when
I say no, no. And will she,
would she jump? And so I
lowered the camera and I said,
I'm afraid of heights and I want
to go downstairs immediately.
And I felt for the first time
just fear. And I called her,
I believe I called her mother
first. Uh, leann. And I just said,
my name is Mike. I'm a
friend of Jamie's and um, I,
I think she may be going through something
and I don't know what I'm dealing
with. I'm in over my head here.
When Mike called, I, uh,
I just got on a red eye that
night. That's Leanne Lantos,
Jamie's mom.
It was my job to get her to go back to
her therapist so that we could get some
medication in her for the end. This
episode was not entirely a surprise.
It had happened once before when Jamie
was in high school. At that time,
she was not sleeping at night,
spinning around the room,
talking nonstop about how she had to
save Central America from disaster.
During the first episode,
Jamie ended up at a place called the
neuropsychiatric institute at UCLA and she
ended up being treated by this guy, Dr
Mark de Antonio. He's a psychiatrist.
She was in a very acute,
manic, psychotic state.
I remember being sort of tackled by
nurses to actually take my meds because I
refused to. We didn't know if we would
ever see our Jamie again. You know,
that was, that was the scariest part.
Everyone around me I think was really,
really worried that I wouldn't come back.
But you did come back and
it's what brought her back.
That is actually the reason I
got so interested in this story.
So shortly after she was admitted, uh,
Dr Dantonio told Jamie's parents we know
what this is and we know how to treat
it. And he said, she's the
classic case of, of bipolar. I,
there was no question and I'm,
the drug of choice is lithium,
which is not even a
drug, but just this salt.
And he's explained to us, um, you
know, that she would need to, um,
take three tablets of lithium,
three tablets of this salt and it
could bring her back when it works.
It's just remarkable.
Do you have memories of like what
it was like to come back like that,
what you were thinking
or what it felt like?
That's really hard to describe.
It's a little bit of like
a slow realization of,
uh, of like, oh, that was a weird
thing that I did a week ago. Like,
why did I do that
the first time she was actually lucid
and coming back to herself again.
The first words out of
her mouth were, mom,
it's not me.
And I just, that just killed me.
[inaudible]
within a few weeks it was like the
incident never happened. So bizarre.
I mean I felt like here was this thing
that's assault that I get to just take
three of a day and and that
was it. Totally normal,
no side effects, no issues.
She went off to college and just
like flourish and it was great.
Things were good for a long time and
then after about six years she said,
you know, I've been on this pill
for six years, had no problems.
I'd like to go off it.
Why don't we try to go off gradually
than about a month after she was totally
off lithium whack in Mike's
apartment up all night.
You were so tired just a minute ago.
That's cause he told me I had to leave,
but now I'm still here. I thought,
oh totally manic episode all over
because I am whatever
you say I am. That's it.
One of the things that kind of makes
lithium that affected lithium has so
spooky,
and you hear this from a lot of people
that have taken lithium to treat bipolar,
is that lithium itself is so
simple. Lithium is an element, right?
It's a single atom. This has been
Lilly, he's a writer, runs a story,
collider podcast.
He's had some personal experience with
psychiatric drugs and he's written about
lithium. That to me was fascinating,
but that a single Adam can
change what we think of,
of who we are. I mean, it's not even,
not just Adam, it's Adam number three,
the third element in the table. It's
one of the simplest Adam's right?
So we have, it's just three protons,
four neutrons, three electrons.
That's a pretty simple in that
matter. I mean, it doesn't get much.
It really is. This had never struck me
when I was on Lexapro or Wellbutrin,
which was the other one they put me
on. You know, if you look at them,
they look like what you expect a
pharmaceutical drug to look like.
There's a ring of carbon atoms and
some other things stuck on it and they,
they look like these big complex
molecules and you're like, Oh yeah, I'm,
I'm complex. My brand is complex. It
takes this complicated thing to change it.
And then you're confronted
with just this Adam,
it was found by accident that
it works. You've just, yeah,
it's not complicated to make,
it's just a salt that you distill out
and yet it has this profound effect.
The other thing I know about lithium
that is, that is profoundly weird,
is that you're not just saying my mind,
my personality is being
changed by an Adam.
It's been changed by an Adam that was
created directly in the Business Bank
itself. So you have this,
Adam formed in the big bang,
goes through whatever it does,
winding path to come onto the earth,
gets dug up, turned into
a pill given to someone.
And that changes their
affect in the world.
And that to me is just,
it's this profound reminder that the,
the forces that shape everything in the
universe are the same as the forces that
are shaping who we are. And what
we do and what our identity is.
It's possible that these forces shaped
not just the people with bipolar
disorder,
but all of us think it was a woman ended
up talking to a clinical psychiatrist
and a fellow who told me about these
studies, huge epidemiologic studies.
The biggest one I think was in Japan.
One was in Austria, one was in Greece,
famous one in Texas in which they looked
at communities that different levels of
lithium with them in the water
supply and we're talking about tiny,
tiny amounts, micrograms.
Those are a thousandth of
the amount in a milligram.
If you think of like a pill of lithium,
well we're talking about
amounts like 10000th of a pill,
like that's the amount that we're dealing
with here and these studies found by
and large in towns that had a tiny
bit more lithium in the water.
Suicide rates were lower in some
cases, as much as 30% I should say.
The Texas study,
which is astonishing also shows that
the towns that have the highest lithium
level have lower felonies, thefts,
rapes, and these are reputable,
published studies. Nope.
These studies are only
showing us correlations,
but there does at least seem to be some
kind of connection and may be if there
is a distinction, what
the hell is it doing?
Do they know why it works in the
brain? Like do they know what it does?
Well essentially no, it's
still kind of a mystery.
But here's a Marc de
Antonio's theory. He says,
we know that bipolar disorder involves
a defect in a certain part of the brain.
It's an area of the brain that
has to do with controlling mood.
So believe it or not, there's neurons
in the brain that keep your mood.
Even these neurons,
they do their job by sort of passing
electricity back and forth and that
electricity is carried by sodium ions.
So the whole system is
pretty much based on sodium.
Lithium is very similar to sodium,
so if you have lithium in the brain,
the neurons will use that to communicate.
They'll send lithium ions back and
forth. And here's what's interesting.
Lithium works just like
sodium, but not as well.
Lithium is similar enough in
properties that it can be an a posture,
but whatever it does, it just doesn't
work as well. That's the key. He says,
so then this area of the brain,
the defective area of the brain that
makes these moods flip on and off so
intensely doesn't work as well
and that stops a bipolar episode.
That's so interesting that maybe it's
sluggishness is what makes it good. Yup.
Yup.
Although he says that same trick where
it can be a sort of sodium imposter but
slower that can also cause the
issues. Slight tremors in your hand.
You can have nausea, they
can affect the kidneys,
the balance of sodium.
Your body is regulated partially
through the kidneys and somehow lithium
replacing it can be toxic to the kidneys,
which actually brings us back to Jamie.
After that episode in New
York with Mike and the video,
she went back on lithium
and again, she was fine.
In fact for the last 16 years
she's been completely normal.
But then a couple months ago I
went to a new primary physician,
mostly because I'm lazy and I didn't want
to go to the upper west side to see my
other doctor.
And this doctor basically took
my blood pressure and was like,
you're gonna die. You
need to go to the Er.
It turns out her kidneys were
failing and so she suddenly
had to make this choice that I could sort
of just stay on lithium and you know,
go to dialysis and get a transplant or
that I had to switch and that now would
be when I would switch that I had enough
function left that I could you you
have, you are in the middle of
that decision now you feel like,
or do you feel like it's decided?
I think I'm going to switch.
I think I made that decision.
It's just that every psychiatrist in New
York leaves for August because I don't
know why, but they all disappear
for August, all of August.
And Mine said you should probably
wait to switch until I come back.
But I, I feel like I have a
good group of people around me.
I have a solid job. I,
it's terrifying to court mania,
but I also feel like there are a lot of
effective drugs and that one of them is
going to work. They won't be as cool as
lithium though. Depakote sounds like.
Oh God. Bra.
You're on Deborah. As she was
in the middle of that decision,
Jamie did one last thing. She
actually took a trip to Bolivia,
which is where much of the
world's lithium comes from.
There's this place you can go and
literally see these massive salt flats,
which are just covered in mountains
of lithium. I just wanted to see them.
I wanted to experience them. I
wanted to be near them. So I went,
uh,
it just looks like a hallucination.
It looks like somebody could not have
conceived of this landscape. You know,
you have red lakes and you have flocks
of flamingos and this like long salty
expands that goes on for
ever. Like it's just huge.
It's enormous. Do you go up to a
pile and put your hand on it? Yeah.
You can.
You stand on it and you jump
off the pile and like, yeah,
I was makings kind of with the [inaudible]
no [inaudible]
and it was awesome.
I know I have to go off
of it, but I really am.
I mean gratitude is like
not even the word. It's,
I feel like this thing allows me to be me.
It doesn't define me,
but it allows for, you know,
functionality and that
sounds kind of Wonky,
but it's like every day I get to
work and it's because of that,
like everything, you know, I'm just,
I'm grateful to it for it
service. I feel like it's, yeah.
Done.
It's done a lot for,
for me.
It worked so hard to get to
me too. From the Big Bang to
now.
Uh, [inaudible]
produce your store on wheeler? No,
Soren is made of elements though,
not of lithium, which we should say only
some of which was made in the big bang.
Some of it was also made ne Supernova
and we'll have one of those coming up.
Special thanks to Ben Lilly and
Harrington. Kay Redfield Jamison,
Steve Lo and of course Jamie Lo.
Jamie working on a book about
her experiences with bipolar.
It will be called grand delusions.
This is a song from the band Sylvan.
So we played them the last story in
progress and they wrote a song about it.
Jen,
do the last thing.
Um,
come phones to me.
Compression scale.
Wow.
It's not me.
Slamdance faster,
faster.
[inaudible]
Diane
[inaudible] came home
[inaudible]
that was Sylvan Esso with Jamie Song.
Do you want to talk? Bang.
Hydrogen was there at zero hundred hours
in the coke colored velodrome of dark
matter gases, checking gases at Infinitum,
chartreuse Flair, then a
deafening birth ions of cosmos.
Cartwheeling Pink, red,
yellow, green, purple, blue,
black and the spear of
night. First I was a star,
then a stain of water,
then a kindergartner.
These poems, by the way, come from the
two events that we held in New York City.
We went to a emotive fruition,
which is a wonderful organization run
by Thomas Dooley, who is himself a poet.
He summoned poets from all around the
metropolitan area and for two nights they
came to the Bell House in
Brooklyn Botanic lab in Manhattan.
And so far we have heard hydrogen by
Sarah Salah, red by Ramsey for our gala,
helium by Christine Kintana. Read
by Junius, Abbott Pratt. And uh,
I carried your oxygen a poem by David
McLaughlin, read by Sam Breslin. Right.
So next up I'm going to give you three
claps. I don't know if you need that,
but just
just in case you need to sync it.
There you go. Good TV guy. Okay,
so a while back we ended up talking to
a guy named Derek Muller who makes a
youtube channel called
[inaudible] awesome,
super popular channel about
science and engineering.
And we called him because he's
making a documentary about uranium.
And we got to talking about what happens
when you take two protons or neutrons
and you just whack put
them together. Yeah, it's,
it's absolutely nuts.
And that led to this really interesting
conversation about the beginning of all
elements. I mean, I feel like a little
bit of backstory is worth saying.
One
really important thing to know is that
combining nuclei gives you energy.
He says when you slam two particles
together, they get squished.
And in the squishing,
they lose a little mass.
That mass gets emitted as energy.
This is equals MC squared. That's
what's happening in the sun right now.
So the sun is taking protons, individual
protons and smashing them together,
combining them. And that gives
you energy. The energy of the sun,
their last mass is the sunlight
that we Baskin, it was mass.
I have never thought of light as as former
mass. Yeah, that's what a star does.
He says it smashes little Adams like
hydrogen together to make bigger.
Adam's like helium and then bigger Adams
like carbon and then even bigger atoms
like oxygen and every little collision
it's doing generates some energy which
keeps the star going.
Stars live by this process
of sticking nuclei together,
going from smaller nuclei, making
bigger nuclei. The heavier the star,
the more the smashing and bashing they
can do in their core and the bigger and
bigger nuclei they can
form. But there are limits.
[inaudible]
6 million years ago that there was this
star giant star whey they got in our son
and uh, it was just doing
its thing, taken Adams and
smashing them together. Combining.
It's taken hydrogen
atoms and making helium,
taking helium Adams and
making carbon, making oxygen,
and as it's smashing all
these nuclei together,
it's releasing energy and getting
bigger and bigger and bigger. But then
there comes a point where sticking nuclei
together no longer gives you energy.
In that point is element number 26 iron.
Once you formed iron, if you're a star,
that's the end of life as you know it
because iron iron is incredibly stable,
one of the most stable
nuclei in the universe.
It's protons are tightly packed in there
and so you can't force any more energy
out of them,
which means you have a core which is
no longer going to give you energy.
You can't cook up anything higher
than, than the iron. That's it.
But what happens to the star? Does it
just become a big punk? What happens is
[inaudible]
everything starts to collapse.
Gravity takes over. That's the thing.
A star maintains its size by the fact
that there's all this energy going out to
this dead iron core starts pulling
everything back in and at this point,
all of that stuff which is headed inwards,
aluminum, oxygen, carbon, magnesium,
silicon starts rubbing against each
other and it starts getting real hot and
real dense, and all of a sudden you get
the supernova.
That was the most pathetic
supernova explosion. Can you put
in a sound effect to make that
sound bath? To put it in the Mexico?
It is actually our specialty.
So even though we know there are no
sounds in space for the purposes of your
enjoyment, we present to you
the Supernova. So here's the beauty of it.
Here's the beauty of the Supernova in the
ridiculous excesses of energy that are
there in the Supernova, right? In
that ridiculously huge explosion,
the biggest in the universe.
There is so much energy there that
actually what happens is you form these
nuclei, which would not form
under any other conditions.
You know, iron hits
carbon to form Germanium,
silicon hits oxygen to form titanium.
You start to get all of these bigger
elements, including like gold,
including the gold in your wedding ring.
They need that extreme ridiculous
excess of energy to form and then
it's done.
And what are you left with? You're
left with a giant field of debris.
Okay.
Ah, there's carbon, there's oxygen,
there's iron, there's silicon,
there's hydrogen, there's helium.
And it starts to clump
together due to gravity.
And the center of that, uh,
which clumps together is our sun is mostly
hydrogen and helium and it's like 99%
of all the mass in our solar
system. And then the other chunks,
other bits and pieces start
to clump together as well.
They have a bit more angular momentum.
So they're spinning around the outside
and those are your planetesimals,
your early planets and,
and that is eventually how you
get the earth and all of us
[inaudible] [inaudible]
this is where we caught you.
So you're saying this is the birth of
everything past iron. Yeah, exactly.
Exactly. It feels like an 80 but I
think I get it for the very first time.
So Post Supernova, like in the,
in the milliseconds post souvenir,
you have lots. You have the whole periodic
table hurling through space. Yeah,
you do. You really do.
[inaudible]
you can find Derek Muller most days
on his youtube channel. Avera Tassian,
his documentary, uranium twisting. The
Dragon's tail will soon appear on PBS.
It has already in fact appeared as
even though already appeared on PBS.
And for some crazy reason it passed me
by coming up a story that will make you
wish the Cold War wasn't over. Not
me, not me. I'm, I'm happy it's over.